good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster it doesn't look to
have been a super thursday at the polls
for secure stamina
the conservatives are set to deliver
another blow to the red wall of labour
northern heartlands
with the parliamentary seat of
hartlepool looking to go blue
for the first time in almost 50 years
they've also made inroads as votes
accounted
in a handful of english councils we'll
speak to the conservative party co-chair
amanda milling in a moment
and also have reaction from labour and
the lib dems
also this morning a pandemic portrait of
our nation
at half past nine we'll chat to a
photographer and a creator from the
national portrait gallery about the
photo book
presenting a unique and personal record
of the country in 2020
and spending ten mindful minutes a day
outside in the garden we'll speak to
former footballer
and mental health advocate wayne bridge
about his campaign to get more people
outside enjoying the summer that's at
quarter to 10.
it's friday the 7th of may
the conservatives seem almost certain to
turn hartlepool blue
as one shadow cabinet minister comes
close to conceding
the by-election it's pretty clear that
the numbers
aren't going our favor to what extent we
just don't know yet it's too early but
over the coming hours uh providing we
stay awake we'll all find out
that sounds like a yes but we'll soon
find out won't we
elsewhere results from a handful of
english councils appear to show a
similar trend of conservative gaining
seats
at labour's expense
this morning concerns over a possible
version of the indian covid variant
as the government prepares to release
its travel green list for england
karma waters tensions ease in the
channel as talks continue to resolve
the fishing dispute between jersey and
france
rio raid at least 25 people including
one policeman
are killed during a shootout in one of
brazil's biggest favelas
and finally it's becoming milder this
weekend but
with that we are seeing wet and windy
conditions at times as well i'll have
the details for you
later in the programme good morning
labor is on calls to suffer a
humiliating defeat in the hartley pool
by-election
heading towards losing a seat they've
held since it was created
nearly 50 years ago after more than
eight hours
the votes are still being counted but in
the early hours labour's shadow
transport secretary
admitted to sky news the party hasn't
got over the line
in the by-election the result will be a
disappointment
to sakirstama's leadership it had said
he was the person
to restore labour's fortunes let's take
you straight across to uh john craig now
and hartley paul for that result
see julian the candidates have just been
called up onto the stage the result is
imminent the winner is going to be uh
jill mortimer the conservative candidate
um question is how big will her majority
be
that behind where those candidates stay
standing
there are a couple of tables which show
just how big the majority is likely to
be
let's listen to the returning
[Music]
for the officers constituency held for
the 6th of may
2021 who here and i gave you notice that
the number of thoughts required
for each candidate is as follows
social democratic party 104 votes
nicholas charles ellsworth delves
commonly known
as the incredible flying brick for the
official
monster raving looney party 108 votes
thank you hilton dawson
the northeast party 163 votes
gemma muncaster commonly known as gemma
evans for the women's equality party
140 votes
rachel sarah featherstone the green
party candidate
358 votes
adam gaines independent 126 votes
andrew michael hagan liberal democrats
349 votes
stephen jack commonly known as steve
jack
freedom alliance no lockdowns no curfews
72 votes
christopher killick commonly known as
chris killick
248 votes
samantha jane lee commonly known as
samli
independent 2904 votes
claire martin for the heritage party 468
votes jillian wendy mortimer
commonly known as jill mortimer
conservative party
candidate fifteen thousand five hundred
and twenty nine
john prescott reform uk 368 votes
thelma doris walker independent 250
votes
william rath war jackson commonly known
as w
bathwar jackson independent 157 votes
and paul daniel williams for the labour
party 8589 votes
the number of ballot papers the number
of ballot papers rejected
was as follows 61 voting for more
candidates than a voter was entitled to
and 121 being unmarked or wholly void
for
uncertainty i through there i do hereby
declare
that jillian wendy mortimer commonly
known as jill mortimer
is dually elected congratulations
[Applause]
so that's the majority of about 7 000
for
jill mortimer here she is now making her
victory speech
[Applause]
thank you madam returning officer
firstly i want to thank the police and
the council officers
who have done an excellent job in
ensuring that today's election and count
went smoothly especially given the
difficult circumstances we've faced
due to the coronavirus pandemic i'd also
like to thank all the candidates
on the stage it's been a tough contest
but it's one that's been fought with
dignity and respect
so thank you all i'm incredibly proud of
the campaign my team and i have run in
hartlepool
um it's based on local issues of real
concern to the community here
and i'd like to thank all of the people
of this great town
who've responded so positively to it
i'm also immensely proud to be the first
conservative
mp in hartlepool for 57 years
um not only that i am the first woman
ever to be elected as mp for this town
[Applause]
it's a truly historic result and a
momentous day
labour of tank people in hartley pull
for granted for too long
um i heard this time and time again on
the doorstep
people have had enough and now through
this result
the people have spoken and they've made
it clear
it's time for change people voted for
that positive
change for jobs and investment and it's
exactly what i'm going to deliver
for now i just want to say a few more
thank yous directly those to those
people who voted for me
who put their faith in me thank you from
the bottom of my heart
um i'm going to work tirelessly for
harley pool and i will not let you down
i will not fail you i'll work with both
the conservative government
and the t side valley mayor and i very
much hope it will once again be ben
houchin and we can celebrate with him
again tomorrow
my thanks also go to cchq everyone in my
fantastic
campaign team and all those who
supported me throughout this a
election including my agent and very
proudly my friend diane clark obie
and of course the wonderful hashon cohan
and of course my heartfelt thanks go to
all of my family
they know who they all are they're more
than just my blood relatives
for their unwavering support
and finally election campaigns are only
made possible by hard-working volunteers
people who are willing to sacrifice
their time pound the streets with us in
as we've seen this time baking sun
frozen letter boxes and hail
political parties rely on the
selflessness of these volunteers
and without them our democracies and
communities would be so much purer
poorer
so thank you all once again thank you
do any of the candidates want to speak
no it's been a really long opinion so
i'm sure you'll like me want to thank
everybody who's been working on the
count this morning
and through the evening and we'll be
back at 10 o'clock for those of you who
want to be here
good night everyone
okay so that uh the result in for
hartley paul john craig's still there
for us a
significant defeat for labour goes
without saying doesn't it john
it's a majority of just under seven
thousand
uh the tories have been delighted by
that they haven't just scraped home here
they've won convincingly
the the jill mortimer's vote was fifteen
thousand
five hundred and something i didn't hear
the rest because of the loud cheers but
fifteen and a half thousand and then
paul williams for labor
eight thousand five hundred eighty
my calculation i think is it's 6940 or
so
it's just under 7 000. so
labor have been not only defeated but
really
really trounced here so if you look at
those numbers
fifteen and a half thousand for the
conservative eight and a half thousand
for labour
not actually that far off the tories
have almost got twice as many votes as
labor
it's a seven thousand majority none of
the other candidates came anywhere
um one of the independents uh was third
and the greens i noticed just edge
excuse me just edged ahead of the
liberal democrats but the story
of the morning is a thumping victory for
the conservatives
by just under 7 000 in as jill
mortimer said a seat that had been
held by labor for 57 years she was also
the first woman mp
for the town she said labor have taken
people for granted for too long
people have had enough the people have
spoken
it's time for change she said so
there we have it we've been here since
uh we've been here more than nine hours
now since the uh the polls closed at ten
o'clock
i think without any doubt it's the
longest count i've certainly ever been
to and i've been to many
um obviously because for various reasons
the covered restrictions
the count was slower fewer counters and
obviously there were four elections
taking place
but uh the conservatives will be
delighted
labour will be distraught at how badly
they've done here the labour inquest
begins
the tory celebrations begin indeed john
i hope you can get some sleep soon well
joining me now
is the co-chair of the conservative
party amanda
milling good morning to you um as we
heard there from john
craig a thumping victory for the
conservatives
what do you put your success down to
well i'm absolutely delighted by the
results and
a huge credit and huge congratulations
to
jill mortimer and the team who've been
working so hard because that's what
they've been doing
they've been working really really hard
over the last few weeks to make the case
as to why people should vote
conservative and in jill's
speech just then she talked about change
labour had taken this seat for granted
and by electing jill should be a
fantastic strong voice
in parliament for the people of
hartlepool working with the government
to deliver for them
how much do you put it down to people
actually actively
voting for the conservative candidate
rather than voting
against labor because they've been
dissatisfied with them
so i think that we had a very strong
message in terms of what we wanted to
deliver
and actually looking around the area
i've been up there six times over the
last few weeks
and you look at what ben houchin has
delivered as the t's value mayor
what conservative mps who were elected
in 2019 have also done
you know they've hit the ground running
and really made the kind of stood up for
their constituents
in parliament so very much about kind of
taking a strong message
in terms of the jobs and investments
that still should be fighting for
for fighting crime for apprenticeships
and so much more
um there will be those who say that
you've actually love bombed
the the area with with with finance the
northeast with with investment um
t-side won freeport status and there'd
be measures to boost the green
energy sector uh town deals were
confirmed for middlesbrough and thornaby
darlington won five million pounds for a
vaccine manufacturing project
1.8 million announced for a cultural
venue
in hartley pool is this what's really
won people over
i think people recognize that this area
has not had a strong voice before and
what we've been doing
our representatives up there have been
really making the case for that
investment in that area
and so and this is about that them kind
of representing their constituents but
also about how we're delivering on our
leveling up agenda in the 2019
general election we talked about
levelling up and all of these kind of
these are all examples of how we're
doing this on the ground
in terms of the the recent stories that
have been
concentrated around boris johnson as an
individual they have been
quite negative uh accusations of sleaze
of corruption much uh spoken about
regarding the the decorations of 10
downing street
has this not played a factor in people's
decisions when they're in the
voting booth so i've been out on the
campaign trail
for many weeks now in fact i've covered
over 5 000
miles knocked on lots and lots of doors
and actually what the people
who i've been talking to are talking
about are the things that these
elections are all about
it's about the local services it's about
keeping streets safe
it's about jobs and investment and so
it's very much those
those have been the points that people
have been discussing but i was up in
hartlepool
only on monday with the prime minister
and the response that he received
from the people of hartford was just
immense
why do you think that is many people
pointing to the fact that this is sort
of personality
politics and because he is popular that
is what he
he thrives on that's what he he trades
on and it's not actually to do with
with the the politics that that he's
putting forward that the party's putting
forward
it's really about celebrity he's popular
but he's also delivered
on those manifesto commitments that we
made in 2019.
let's take hartley paul as an example
they voted 69.5
to leave in the 2016 referendum we made
the promise the prime minister made the
promise in the general election
that we would get brexit done and that's
very much what we did
last year and we've made a number of
promises and we're making inroads in
terms of
recruiting more police officers we're
recruiting more nurses
more money for the nhs and education so
they see that we are actually delivering
almost those policies that we promised
back in 2019.
do you think the saber rattling with a
jersey
added to his uh popularity in the polls
at this particular time
i think that matthew you know what
happened in jersey was about protecting
those people in jersey and that was a
policy decision for very good reasons
uh turning to the pandemic which has
been um
overarching all of our lives for the
last year or so
what what is happening with the
uncertainty around travel are we going
to find out which countries
are going to be on the green list
something we've been waiting for for a
long time
so um colleagues in government will be
making announcements on that front
shortly you'll understand from my point
of view
i've literally been out and about on the
campaign trail and and focusing on the
elections
but when you say shortly do we have a
date because you'll appreciate
that the travel industry and also
individuals who want to
to make a decision about whether they do
in fact travel this summer
that they need to know cost implications
are uh are apparent
i know i know people are very keen to
kind of get the certainty
and that that will be provided a very
soon
as and when as i say government
colleagues will be making an
announcement in due course but i
understand
why people are so keen to know more
because they do want to
know whether they can get that sunshine
break or they'll have to say over the
recent weeks we've been
benefiting from a sunshine here in the
uk would you advise your constituents to
travel
it's totally up to constitutions i
understand why they might have concerns
in terms of this but it's
important that we get it right it's
important that we ensure that
um you know people who do go on holiday
can do
safely might we get an announcement
today i'm not going to get drawn into
when the announcement is going to be
but all i will say is that that
announcement will come forward so people
have got that certainty okay minister
thank you very much for uh speaking to
us this morning
your smile is still there a very happy
morning for you indeed
still to come on the show at quarter to
eight we'll hear from the deputy leader
of the liberal democrats
daisy cooper
and from five past eight the shadow
communities and local government
secretary steve reed will be in the
studio
representing labor
let's take you to the newsroom now and
our election analyst michael thrasher
who can bring us all the latest results
and analysis of course as well as
his own projections uh doing well you've
been up for a very very very long time
uh much longer
than normal because this is in a
situation like no other kovid held up
the count
and therefore everything is a little
later how how are we looking now across
the board
well it was worth waiting for wasn't it
um
we're used to seeing big swings in
by-elections and this one
is a big swing 16 swing
but what we're not used to seeing is a
swing from the opposition
to the governing party this is the
largest
percentage point increase for a
governing party
at a by-election since the war um
so it's quite a spectacular turnaround
uh in a seat that labor should really
have
safely defended the conservatives have
taken it and
it only becomes the fifth by-election
since the war
that a government party has taken from
the opposition so
it's really quite remarkable and it
follows on from
a set of local election results that
also promised to be
remarkable too and none of this is good
news for the labour party
uh and uh michael is it that the
conservatives have um
done everything correctly or is it that
labor
has failed well
i think you'd have to say a little bit
of each i think the conservatives
have clearly taken a lot of the vote
that used to go
to uh euro skeptics ukip uh
but they've also managed to as they did
in the last general election in december
2019
what they've also done has again
persuaded
former labor voters to again
support them in the local elections so
the december 2019 result wasn't a flash
in the pan
it appears that um the conservatives
have made
serious inroads into traditional labor
support so much so that they've gained a
seat which labor
have held for many many years
michael thank you very much not sure if
you can go to bed just yet
but we'll we might see a little later on
thank you
well in other news the major protests
over fishing rights at jersey's main
port ended last night as french
fishermen and two
royal navy ships returned her home
jersey's government held what it's
described as
positive and constructive talks with the
fishermen who had been furious
at demands they obtained new licenses to
carry on operating in jersey's waters
after brexit
let's get the latest now from our
correspondent ashna harinag
who's in jersey for us uh morning ashna
and
is it completely over now i thought that
some ships were remaining just to keep
an eye on things over the weekend
it definitely isn't over that's for sure
i think that's the short answer if you
like but there is definitely that strong
sense of feeling here at the port
not only from fishermen but from fish
merchants we've spoken spoken to as well
this morning who say that
jersey feels as though it is the joke of
the world this morning
they are waking up here after the
theatrics of yesterday which saw
some 60 or 70 uh french fishing vessels
pull into the port behind me
as for the politicians here on the
islands they tried to manage this with
diplomacy many of them taking to the
water
yesterday talking to the french
fishermen about what they wanted the
french are furious
over this documentation this new
procedure that they say is putting their
livelihoods at risk but as for the
french
as for the jersey fishermen they too are
angry this is very much a battle between
the two
as for jersey and france and the uk they
have been sharing the waters behind me
for decades there is huge history here
but they knew that come the brexit deal
come the brexit agreement being signed
there was bound to be teething problems
but no one could have foreseen the
confrontation
that happened yesterday it has to be
said it was largely peaceful
but now the battle very much on the
decision
makers shoulders to find out exactly how
it's going to impact the people here in
jersey
but certainly from these guys's
perspective they're not willing to back
down
and they're many that say that you know
they can see both sides of the the
argument but the
emphasis now has to be on the the future
relationship because
that the technicalities in terms of
licenses has changed
so they have to move forward and work
with the new rules
yeah that's right the the jersey
politicians from their perspective and
from the uk government we heard from
george eustis yesterday
saying that things have changed now and
we need to move with the times
but the problem is that you've got a
huge uh
vast um area of france that many of the
jersey fishermen aren't able to go in
and their argument is well
if we can't go into your waters if
you're not granting us the licenses
we're not kicking up a fuss
what about um why do you want it that
you want to come in here too
and use our waters and also it's not a
case of
blocking off the jersey waters the
jersey shores it's more a case of
them having to apply for licenses but
applying for them in a very different
way so using
um proving for example that they've got
records dating back to say
2016 and maybe even further afield the
latest that we've heard is that from the
french side of things they
are suggestions this morning that there
could be the port of calais that might
be their next
target if you will on the jersey side
they say
that if the government here if the
politicians here back down
they may well stage their own protest
ashland thank you
public health experts have recommended
that a version of the indian covid19
variant be listed as a variant of
concern by the government
it comes as various clusters of the
b16172 variant have been discovered
across
england well now correspondent ender
brady joins me
now and uh a worrying development for
sure but but just how worried should we
be
so there's no indication that these
variants which were first detected
in india can evade the vaccines that's
the positive news this morning we're
likely to hear more from public health
england
in the coming hours about what's
happening here in total
there are reports of 48 clusters
of this variant across the country cases
have been found now
in the northwest of england in london
and in the east midlands
all of which are linked to travel now
of those 193 confirmed cases
we're hearing reports as well seven have
been confirmed in northern ireland but
as i say
no sign yet that this indian variant
can evade the vaccination program so we
may hear more from public health england
later today and of course this coming on
the day when the government is set to
outline
the green list of travel where countries
where people will be able to
perhaps go away after may the 17th when
international travel
opens back up again and the factors that
they've been looking at and studying
to get these countries onto that green
list you need
rates of infection to be low a high
percentage of the population
who have already been fully vaccinated
against covert 19
and also keeping an eye on those
emerging new variants reports this
morning
that there will only be 10 countries
making that
green list later today okay and uh
the moment thank you so much uh well
let's give you um a result uh
just in the latest that we have from
doncaster
uh we'll just bring that up for you and
you can see that it's a
labor hold uh vote there thirty 31
232 to the conservative candidate james
hart 21019
turnout 27.7
there so labour hold in doncaster
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning still a fairly cool and
showery day for today but it's one more
day of that
before it becomes milder this weekend
but also turning rather wet and windy
courtesy of this
low pressure system bringing through
some heavy rain and strong winds
this morning a chilly start quite frosty
some showers around northern and western
areas and they'll become more widespread
through the day around central and
northern parts of the uk then later
becoming confined to northern and
eastern areas
in between dry and brighter spells but
some of them like previous days could be
heavy and thundery
and maybe wintry across the high ground
in the north but for much of ireland
wales
most of the midlands and central and
southern and eastern england will be a
mainly dry afternoon and
feeling fairly mild temperatures
slightly higher than recently but
tonight
wet and windy wet windy tomorrow as well
the conservatives have made history in
hartley pool this morning
winning the by-election by a majority of
6940.
it's the first time ever the
conservatives have taken this seat from
labour
delivering another blow to the party's
red wall of northern heartlands
well this was the moment the count was
announced
jillian wendy martimer commonly known as
jill martimer
conservative party candidate fifteen
thousand five hundred and twenty nine
conservative jill mortimer won the seat
with more than half of the votes cast
and a swing from labour of almost 16
she described it as an historic day
i'm incredibly proud of the campaign my
team and i have run in hartlepool
it's based on local issues of real
concern to the community here
and i'd like to thank all of the people
of this great town who've responded so
positively to it i'm also
immensely proud to be the first
conservative mp
in hartlepool for 57 years
not only that i am the first woman ever
to be elected
as mp for this town
it's a truly historic result and a
momentous day
earlier i spoke to the conservative
party co-chair amanda milling who
explained why
she believed the tories won this seat
they've been working really really hard
over the last few weeks to make the case
as to why people should vote
conservative and in jill's
speech just then she talked about change
labour had taken this seat for granted
and by electing jill should be a
fantastic strong voice
in parliament for the people of
hartlepool working with the government
to deliver for them
well let's take you across to jane
secker now in the sky news center who
can dive into the data of the local
elections
a little bit uh more for us we're
expecting
jane to yeah take us through now there
she is morning
hi jillian yeah well uh as we just said
we've got the by-elections we've got the
hartlepool by-elections also got local
mayoral elections lots of other
elections but
uh a really big thing that's also
happened over the last 24 hours are the
local
council elections now this is a really
big year for local councils because
as well as the 2021 council elections
there's also
the last year's council elections the
2020 ones which were deferred
because of covid so let's see if we can
bring those up here on the screen and
see what results we have so far now
obviously a sea of white we have got
lots and lots and lots of results still
to come through but there are some
that have come through already uh we can
see that labour have held a lot of the
northern seats sunderland south tyneside
newcastle gateshead
perhaps no surprise that they've held
those seats but we're going to
take a look at how strongly they've held
them in a short while
but good night for the conservatives so
far
harlow they've taken down their and
essex nuneaton and bedworth
and redditch both of those up in the
midlands
now those are significant because harlow
they took seven out of the eight
uh labor seats that were up on that
council and conservatives last
controlled it in 2011
and non-eaton uh up there in the
midlands
uh they took 10 out of the 11 seats that
the labour
uh were trying to contest there uh the
conservatives last had control of that
council back in 2019.
so let's see how this translates into
actual seats
uh these are the seats uh labour 108
down 38 the conservatives 84
up 40 the lib dems held a couple up two
with 30 and the greens up three this is
how those seats then translate into
councils labour have five down one the
conservatives have four
up two and other three
which is down one but let's look at
these in a little bit more detail
and this really shows us yes labour have
taken
one seat lost a few conservatives uh
have certainly gained but it shows you
just how much
that the conservat the labour losses are
big losses they've lost
39 seats and the conservative gains
are big gains um if we quickly look at
the councils
uh where that this shows us where the
councils are now
conservatives have four labor five
uh conservatives gaining two and labour
losing one
early days lots and lots more councils
still to declare
but the early signs are showing it's
been a good night for the conservatives
so far jane thank you back to you
a little later on let's get more now on
the local election results as hartley
paul has turned blue for the first time
in almost 50 years joining me now
is former conservative mp justin
greening and the former
labour mp caroline flint good morning to
you both um
to you first of all caroline plint uh
very unusual for a governing party to
win
a by-election what do you think labour
got so drastically wrong
well we've had a poor night so far in
the northeast and the catastrophic loss
of hartlepool but also
in the midlands as well i think in the
post-mortem
labor has to ask itself some really hard
questions
uh was the candidate the labour
candidate the right choice an ardent
remainer
for hartley paul in this by-election was
the date
of the by-election the right choice
given we had the tease valley election
as well but i think too it's really
important to understand as well that in
the last
six weeks labor has been obsessed with
curtains in downing street and dyson and
ventilators
and that was not cutting through to the
public and that was clear from the
telephone canvassing and it was clear on
the doorstep
there are real lessons to learn and part
of it is how does labor reconnect with
working class communities in the north
and in the midlands
in a way that they accept that they let
them down labour let them down in 2019
not the reverse just picking up on that
point that you mentioned that perhaps
the wrong candidate
uh was chosen justin greening that was
also the accusation uh
against uh jill mortimer that she wasn't
a local but
in the event it didn't seem to matter
yeah i think brexit broke the mold it it
broke down those tribal loyalties but
the defining issue in this election and
i think for this country now on is
leveling up
and the difference between the two
candidates and i think the two parties
is that the conservatives had a plan on
leveling up that was credible
and was about that local community and
labor didn't
and i think there's a lot of labour
activists there's a lot of labour mps
who
understand what leveling up is why it
matters so much i just don't think the
labour leadership
have got it and until they're willing to
accept that
they need to compete on a better
leveling up vision
for the country and for the communities
they want to win in again
i think labor will continue to continue
its downward slide
caroline would you agree with that that
they haven't got the message labour
hasn't got the message
clear enough on levelling up in in these
areas
well leveling up is really important i
mean i think we have to
some at some point define what leveling
up actually means i don't think a lot of
people in hartlepool
uh and elsewhere in the country um in
these local elections quite understand
what that means but what is true
is labour has to be a party that speaks
about
hope for the future and part of that
hope for future is a better sharing of
the resources of our country
across a wider community it has to
decide
and kirstama has to decide is labour
only going to be viewed
as the voice of liberal-minded city and
university towns
or is it actually going to be a voice
for those working-class communities
in some of our smaller places like
hartlepool like doncaster
like redditch like nuneaton and that's
the real issue
and then on top of that you get to how
do we grow our economy
in order to be able to provide the sort
of futures that people can want for
themselves and their kids and their
grandkids
and there's a really important way in
which labor can do that
but part of the reconnection is not to
just say we've listened we've changed
you really have to engage with people
that we let them down
we let those working-class voters down
in 2019
both in terms of the leader jeremy
corbyn but also in terms of brexit and
we need to move on from that
but there needs to be a level of
contrition by labour when they approach
these voters and say we're listening
justin greening from what uh caroline
clint's saying there it seems that it
it was well we know it definitely
technically was labour's to lose
but it's because of what they haven't
done correctly why there has been
a conservative success rather than
anything the conservatives have done
to bring about this result if that is
the case
uh it's it's not sustainable is it
see i think voters do understand what
leveling up's about they do
get that it is about people having the
same chances to get on in life
wherever they are and as caroline says
whether they're in the city whether
they're in a town whether
they're growing up in a rural area i
think voters do get it
and i think they are wanting to see
which party has the best plan
on leveling up and the parties with the
best plan on leveling up
win elections i think it is actually
that simple
leveling up is the big alignment that's
happening in
the country it's less about left and
right now and i think whilst the labour
party continued to obsess on
where they are on the left right
spectrum and brexit then i think
they won't move on to this core issue
that actually
is the one that does bring people
together which is having the same
opportunities the conservatives were
talking about how to bring
investment both from the public sector
the private sector how to create jobs
and opportunities for people in
hartlepool that's what everybody wants
wherever they live
and that's why the conservatives are
doing well in winning by elections
in places like hartlepool really for the
first time i have to also say
it is fantastic to see another woman mp
in parliament
long overdue probably in harley hartley
pool and it's brilliant that voters have
voted for jill mortimer congratulations
to her yeah she did say herself that the
first
female mp in in that that area um
you mentioned about what people are
pulling together over and one of the
things that that we've all had to pull
together over is the pandemic and
caroline flint
it has to be said the vaccination
program has been a huge success that
attributed
to to boris johnson um would you say
that that
has been the reason for the boris
johnson bounces it's been described
certainly the case and we've known this
even before the vaccination program and
i'm a vaccination center volunteer
myself so i meet people all the time
who are delighted at getting their
vaccines um
but i think it's also about in the
pandemic what we've heard over the last
year
is people saying look you know mistakes
have been made
but to a certain extent whoever was in
government might have made those
mistakes
and as we've come through this year i'm
sure there's lots of things the public
don't think the government's done well
but overall
they're glad to have got through it and
they're glad they're getting the
vaccines
and i think again this was one of the
reasons why it was so important kirsten
actually did make some really important
strategic choices
he did choose to not just oppose the
government on everything they were doing
on the pandemic and that was the right
choice
um and people want to know that there is
that sort of sense of the
country pulling together and yet the
vaccine bounces there but i think
importantly it's recognizing this that
in somewhere like hartley pool
um it only didn't become a touristy
in 2019 because of the brexit vote that
was there
as soon as that brexit vote has
disappeared it didn't come back to
labour
as some in labor just thought it might
do it actually went to the tories
and if it had been the case that brexit
wasn't standing in more labour seats in
2019
we would have lost yvette cooper we'd
have lost ed miliband and many other
seats
to the tories and so as i say in this
post-mortem
labor kirstama has to really seriously
ask some hard questions of itself
and understand this is not about
pleasing the membership of the labour
party
it's reaching out to those communities
that actually are about why labour
exists
those working class communities that
founded the labour party yeah it'd be
very interesting to sit in on those uh
post-election uh discussions
with the shadow cabinet uh caroline
flynn and justine greening thank you
very much for showing your views with us
this morning thank you
thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast uh we'll be getting the latest
reaction from the deputy leader of the
liberal democrats
as the conservatives gain hartley paul
from labour
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a forgotten front line they are
dying here
[Music]
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
i believe home did that it's pretty
special isn't it
[Applause]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone
they can't arrest everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
[Music]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
most of island wales the midlands and
central and southern england will be
mainly dry
and bright this afternoon elsewhere
we'll see showers some of them locally
heavy with the risk of hail and thunder
especially in the north and east
it'll still be cool for the time of year
but temperatures will be slightly higher
than recently
pollen levels will be generally moderate
today with tree pollen such as birch oak
and ash airborne during the fine and
sunny weather
high levels are likely in the southeast
plain pollen is likely in some cities
too and spores will increase temporarily
after any showers
the pollen reports sponsored by phillips
connected air purifiers
well back to our continuing coverage of
the local elections the deputy leader of
the liberal democrats uh joins me now to
discuss the conservatives win
in hartley paul and what this will mean
for the future of the
country good morning to you uh good to
speak to you
um first of all tell us what you make of
the the result in
in hartley pool and what this means for
the wider political landscape
well it's very clearly a good result for
the conservative party nobody can deny
that
um but i think that there are probably a
number of factors at play here
the first is that the conservatives have
clearly won the brexit vote
the second of course um is that
there were some local factors affecting
the previous
labour mp who had to stand down and
thirdly
there is no doubt that there has been
this vaccine bounce
but i think longer term what we'll see
is that the public will want to
judge the conservative government not
only on their broader handling the
pandemic
but also how they handle their recovery
as we look to the future and people and
fellow ends and people face the prospect
of unemployment
um and rising cost of food
and what does it specifically tell us
about labor in that area
well i think labour themselves have said
this morning that they need to listen
reconnect um and what we've seen from
results not just in hartley pool but
across the northeast
is that labor are actually losing seats
to lots of different parties
and i'm very pleased to see that liberal
democrats have uh held their ground
in um gateshead and newcastle and of
course we've made four games in
sunderland
as well um so i think labour clearly has
um big issues to to work out but as i
say it's not just that they're losing
uh they've all just lost hardly promoted
conservatives but they're losing local
seats
to lots of different parties as well and
what's your relevance
in all of this i mean we are very much
seeing that it's a two-party
uh system that's what it looks like in
operation do you think the liberal
democrats are still relevant
yes absolutely and that's why we've seen
games
in areas such as sunderland and that's
why we've managed to hold our ground
in newcastle and gateshead as well the
fact is that with hartley paul
it's a by-election and by-elections are
pretty much always framed
as a fight between two particular
parties hartlepool was no different it
was framed as a fight between the
conservatives
and labor and that meant that other
smaller parties were not going to get a
look in
so i'm really pleased that we are making
gains in in other areas
of the northeast a long way that
continue you say that it was framed
as a two-party race uh in hartley pool
but
nationally that that's really how
politics is framed and
do you think that people believe that
there is any point
to voting liberal democrat yes i think
so
uh you know the fact is that there are
large parts of the country where only
the liberal democrats
can beat the conservatives we have um
been very outspoken in pre in last few
months
about various liberal issues we have
been um
leading the charge for the right to
protest we have been
leading the charge against the
government holding powers that it
doesn't need
uh during um just some during some of
its emergency corona virus legislation
so we've been very outspoken this year
on a number of issues
and i think people not only um see that
we're the only party standing up for
liberal values
but we are also the only party that can
beat the conservatives in large parts of
the country
uh these have been at davie's first uh
elections and
it's apparent that the party has moved
away from its
brexit line uh people may be thinking
that you don't hold your course and and
you
change with the wind no that's not right
i mean
we have always been pro-europeans it's
in our blood as liberals
we're pro-europeans we're
pro-internationalists and we've never
shied away from that but we're also
community activists
and our community values are part of um
our philosophy and part of our ideology
as a party
and that's why at local elections we
pride ourselves on having candidates who
are part of their communities
and we'll see over the course of the
next 48 hours uh what the results are
like for the liberal democrats as
results start to come in over saturday
and sunday
in local councils across england you are
a party
of opposition and you've tried to throw
a couple of punches on the prime
minister as regards
sleazer and corruption but but nothing
seems to
to have stuck do you regret taking that
that line of uh attack
no not at all um i think for the moment
a lot of people are maybe reserving
judgment
to see what the findings are of various
investigations um but we have to
remember that
the um allegations are serious enough
that the electoral commission has
announced an investigation
that there are a number of parliamentary
inquiries in all sorts of accusations to
do with
uh you know cash for contracts there is
ongoing legal cases demanding
transparency from the government that
they so far refused to give
and it's absolutely right and proper
that all these investigations run their
course
the prime minister and the conservative
party that they've said that
it was simply tittle tattle and the
voters didn't care about
it i mean they've been proved right
haven't they well this is one this is a
one by-election and it's a snapshot um
and as i say there are lots of different
factors at play in hartley pool
um but the fact is as i say these
accusations have only been made in the
last sort of ten days or so
and there are a number of investigations
that will have to run their course and
at the end
when more information is available the
public will be able to
um make their judgement then daisy
cooper lib dem deputy leader thank you
very much for speaking to us this
morning
thank you let's take a look at the
weather for you now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning one more day of the cool
and showery weather but then
into the weekend yes it turns milder but
watch out for this
because that's going to bring wet and
windy conditions particularly through
saturday
until then it's a fine start out there
this morning most places dry and sunny
chilly yes and a bit frosty in some
spots and there are a few showers
scattered around northern western areas
some of them are turning wintry across
the high ground of the north and then as
we go into this afternoon
the showers will become more widespread
for many central northern parts of the
uk
in between sunny spells like previous
day some of them could get heavy in
sundry particularly as they become
confined towards northern and eastern
areas
of scotland and england into this
afternoon with a risk of hail
and maybe some thundery downpours but
elsewhere particularly across ireland
wales most of england there will be
lots of dry weather and some sunshine
and slightly milder than
recently but the southwest becomes
cloudy and windy by the end of the day
with heavy rain strong winds spreading
eastwards